pape sy à des guest stars dans ce film
il ya thuram et à ronaldinho il ya
okocha et à jean tiberi qui officie au
cours d'un mariage blanc
pour vous aider à devenir français il
vous marie avec une une grosse noire un
vrai je suis loin d'elle au départ c'est
un beau coup on a vraiment c'est ça
réunit les opposer jean tiberi qui fait
des mariages blancs donc finalement ce
n'est pas un rôle de composition
et puis il ya aussi beaucoup de bonnes
répliques
l'agent qui vous faire signer serge
riaboukine qui vous dit tu vois tibor
c'est avec ce stylo que thuram a signé
son premier contrat mairie mais ça donne
envie
ça donne envie ouais sauf qu'après vous
apprenez que d'habitude il dit pas
parfait avant ils disaient pas pareil il
ya d'armes ont donc l'agent terry boss
car qui dit et si la créatine tu verras
jugée comme une phrase un mot élite qui
restera et puis à un autre qui est
nickel sylvain qui est jouée par stomy
bugzy qui dit tant que j'ai pas lu le
pognon vous verrez pas la marque
je garde le cirage sur mes pompes mais
je pense que c'est un excellent plus
haut bien sûr tout tout tout tout c'est
une situation toutes ces anecdotes sont
tirés de trucs qui sont vraiment qu'ils
prennent leur source dans la réalité
dans les faits c'est pour ça que c'est
drôle c'est pour ça qu'on en rit
beaucoup
alors 3-0 après le raid vous êtes une
star
ouais on peut dire ça oui je suis
content quand l'actualité rapprocher
comme ça c'est vrai que là moi j'suis
assez exposé donc et je me rends compte
que j'ai plein d'ennemis maintenant il
ya plein de gens qui me critiquent c'est
là que je me rends compte que peut-être
elle devient une star il ya de la
jalousie la chiffa et met un alors le
plus incroyable c'est que vos parents
sont des travailleurs immigrés hongrois
et que donc oui enfin moi ma mère ma
mère est née en france
voilà c'est mon papa qui lui c'est
vraiment un plan d'eau les ouais je suis
beaucoup inspiré vie pour la coupe de
cheveux et vous vouliez de footballeur
comme j'étais petit c'est un rêve que
vous réalisez à travers à travers ce
film exactement jouais bien je me
débrouille je me défoule mais là j'en ai
fait mon deuil là j'ai pris j'ai pris
conscience du décalage que j'ai avec des
vrais professeurs alors voir comment
vous êtes revenu
alors là on a montré de loin à un prix
de très loin ah bah non non mais quand
même il ya pas mal de trucs dans 75
quand même hein ça commence 1,75
car dans l'orne dans 61 masson et la
presse était invitée dans 72 voilà dans
la sarthe je suis resté trois mois dans
leur travail alors vos parents c'est
parce qu'ils étaient étrangers qui vous
ont appelé laurent l eau et rhein t on à
un problème est que notre monde famille
mon nom c'est deutsch et ça veut dire
allemand ouais et j'ai rien contre les
allemands 1 quoi qu'ils nous ont volé la
coupe du monde en 54 ont droit ça c'est
pour les petits cependant ce qu'ils ont
fait pire de place
non sinon ça va je respecte les
allemands mais là le peu de la coupe du
monde c'était la goutte d'eau et tout le
monde me disait heureusement que je
m'appelle lauranne l eau à rikers on
s'interrogeait sas a interpellé mon
prénom et on n'a jamais dit heureusement
tes potes originalement de toits des
maisons alors que si je m'étais appelé
un autre prénom moi moi j'ai des photos
là j'étais condamné la l'agent du
bouffey de la choqué toute ma vie
alors en 6e vous mesuriez un maître 11 h
un record du monde absolu - mais vous
avez pu faire jockey ouais mais j'aime
pas le cheval face à son nom en principe
c'est une bonne forme et en théorie ça
peut le faire mais j'aimerais et c'est
vrai qu'on vous a appelé longtemps à m
ouais ça presse internet 26 sont 3e et
c'était assez pénible puberté à 18 ans
record du monde là encore c'est cumulant
je suis désolé j'en ai cure et plus d'un
ce soir mais j'ai pas mal de records du
monde à mon actif
la puberté la [ __ ] aussi ce qui fait
qu'à 15 ans vous êtes dans un centre de
détection et entre autour de moi il ya
des sportifs qui sont déjà pas mal
accompli physiquement notamment déjà
bondée comme on dit chez nous des noirs
et j'ai pu vérifier la légende et à côté
moi c'était bon et même un petit noir
avait un truc énorme à côté de moi ils
avaient tous des deux les baguettes en
2011 a laissé faire
c'est celle en deuil donc vous vous
arrêtez les sportifs ils sont tous
taillés dans un an dans un chêne et moi
j'ai été taillée dans un angle ans donc
des bons possible pour trouver un peu
comme un conte faut bien dire mais comme
vous étiez comme vous étiez une vraie
pile électrique vous fassiez quelque
chose et là vous commencez le théâtre
voilà way au départ j'avais découvert ça
un petit peu en retournant sur sable et
avant la transition vers vers paris j'ai
accompagné mon meilleur ami et je
l'accompagné au théâtre parce que si là
où il ya le plus de filles au niveau du
foot on est très frustrés parce que dans
les vestiaires évidemment c'est
exclusivement masculin et moi je suis
vraiment la dernière roue du carrosse
dans ce cas là puis même la fille moi la
fille du vestiaire c'est moi et au
théâtre par contre c'est là que il ya
plein de filles et tous et j'aime bien
faire l'intéressant l'idiot la face il
est et je prends du plaisir à aller sur
la scène pour faire les improvisations
des trucs comme ça et ça commence comme
ça et là et débarquer à paris devraient
que six mois plus tard oui comme un
grand oui quoique théâtre j'essaie du
cinquième but des ces web premier
casting glg de là j'ai vraiment de la
chatte parce que mon premier casting je
suis pris et c'est pour une grande
aventure c'est pour un an de tournage là
encore matin il m'a aidé parce que
c'était pour jouer le rôle d'un petit
aventurier qui était censé avoir 10 ans
10 11 ans j'en avais 16 et j'en faisais
8 donc c'est un plus
mais j'ai pu faire le truc quand même un
et vous partez plus d'un an au québec
ah ouais en deux fois je suis pas deux
fois six mois canada et c'était c'était
pour moi génial parce que j'avais connu
que la sarthe
ouais même temps même le cantal c'est
énorme jeudi j'ai découvert la culture
américaine mais avec le canada allait
donc chemise et où j'étais comme un fou
mais vous savez faire l'accent québécois
jeu tarn et l'acheteur et oui mon fils
mon petit français la cg cliff simon
prenait aïeul la tavarn assez bien parti
de caen lisent aussi bref c'est du rap
game c'est garder le mal est il vraiment
le père bien réagir
c'est vers quoi comme accent à part le
marcellier qu'on a vu le québécois qu'on
a vu que c'est faire coiffer par ici il
suffit de me demander moi j'ai mon idole
c'est benoît poelvoorde et comme je suis
assez bien j'ai pris l'accent belge à
pourvoir attention il mute anciens
monopoles mots
c'est vraiment un boulot fait de la télé
ou fête du cinéma est bien